legends of the wrong nuts
the Targaryen is use dragging back to
decorate the weapons about even I want
the first men used it for it's a matter
of Dragonstone the Targaryen was built
there for strong cold air when the
invaded Westeros got a dragon crush a
mountain loving hey youtubers it's
Charlie hopefully you've seen episode
one by now but we have to talk about
dragonglass how it is critical it is now
the cause of in solution to all the
problems on the show
it goes back to ancient Valyria there's
material on the pages that Samwell is
reading that talks about how the ancient
Valerians before the Targaryens came to
Westeros use dragon glass so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to explain
what's on the pages of Sam wells reading
I'll actually read some of the text in
how it's going to work into the show
because now we know that it's also a
curative for greyscale so it's almost
like Samwell is the ultimate exposition
tool on the show now he has the books
that will literally explain everything
oh my god we have to tell John about
this but if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's special Comic Con stuff
happening this week and all explained at
the end of the video game of Thrones
invited me to like a special party
tonight so I'll be posting a bunch of
pictures from that when I make it but
let's start at the beginning here
dragonglass we know that it was used to
create the night king the children of
the forest using their magic bound one
of the first men to a weirwood in
stabbed him in the heart with
dragonglass turning him into the night
king the ultimate weapon of mass
destruction the way that lief explained
it to brand is that the first men were
getting ready to wipe them out so as a
measure of last resort they created
something so terrible that would destroy
everything but when they created them to
destroy the first man they didn't
realize that it would literally end up
destroying everything and now brands had
this vision of the night king bringing
the winter with them
we actually rewatching this scene it
seems like he's walking on green grass
so he is south of the wall so that means
as of this moment right here
he's south of Winterfell because it's
snowing at the cottage where the Hound
is and that's way further south of
Winterfell
meaning that bran might wind up seeing a
version of Daenerys his vision with
King's Landing covered in snow in ruins
we know that it can be used to kill
White Walkers they shatter like ice
sculptures but now based on samwell's
book we learn what the ancient Valerians
did with it in what its other uses are
there have been a lot of theories that
it's utilized in the creation of
balerion stele I'll get into that too
first just dragonglass then I'll
tangentially talk about Valyrian steel
because it's another really big thing
for season 8 Samwell brushes over most
of this backstory like he's presumably
going to read this in more detailed
fashion but he's sort of skimming
through it the first time until he
notices the dragon stone drawing and
thinks of Jon Snow oh my god there's a
mountain of dragonglass we can use it to
kill White Walkers he hasn't started
thinking about its other uses yet you
look over at this side of the page here
and even though you can't make out the
full sentences you see dragonglass as a
cure then down here work on illnesses so
what a coincidence that right after this
scene we see Sir Jorah stick his hand
out that's the only part of him you see
the greyscale covered arm has the dragon
Queen come back right after Samwell got
done reading about dragonglass
and reading about Dragonstone trying to
get Jon Snow to go there to get
dragonglass so they're doing a lot of
table-setting trying to give you all
this exposition like oh my god wait a
minute does that mean that sir Jorah is
going to try and use dragon glass to
cure his greyscale and go to Dragonstone
at the same time there's so much more on
these other pages too that you don't see
because sand will just skips right past
it you see the cat's-paws Valyrian
dagger that's actually a picture in
reference to the way the Valyrian would
use dragon glass to adorn their weapons
so it's a Valyrian blade with a dragon
glass hilt already that seems pretty
special but you can actually make out
this sentence pretty clearly up here
where it says the Valyrian were familiar
with dragonglass
long before the Targaryen came to
Westeros they used to call it frozen
fire what they would do is they would
use drag
and fire to melt the Obsidian and shape
it into buildings monuments they would
create seamless structures so you see
what they're trying to do they're trying
to explain that you need dragon fire to
create really ornate dragon glass
weapons you can you know bind it to
Spears you can use it in a really simple
way the way the children of the force
would use it you just carve yourself a
little obsidian knife and you're good to
go but there's so many more
sophisticated things that you can do
with it namely this is a hat tip for
Valyrian steel and for the dragon stone
itself like it's literally a fortress
made from dragon glass in the natural
rock formations like they say they use
it as this sort of additive material to
create sculptures to create these
seamless structures it's almost like the
idea of dragon glass is woven into the
DNA of the idea of Targaryen Zin the
Dragons there's been a long-standing
theory that the Valyrians used obsidian
and dragon fire to create Valyrian steel
it's sort of an alloy of normal steel
you mix obsidian with regular steel you
use dragon fire to smelt it but that's
not the end of it that's just the idea
that this is now a big additive material
for Valyrian steel we're working up to
that
like we know obsidian is good we're
looking for that but it's Samwell has
stolen his family's blade heart's pain
hopefully he won't melt that down to try
and find out if there's obsidian in it
we'll probably eventually see them
creating more Valyrian steel before
season 8 now because that's such a
complex process and it involves
characters actually learning all these
things and then having a really good
Smith say like Gendry teach other people
how to do it you're not going to see a
bunch of characters next week roll out
with a bunch of Valyrian weapons and
Valyrian armor the one piece of the
Valyrian steel theory that I haven't
seen so far and I couldn't find any
reference and they need a text in these
books which doesn't mean it's in here
it's just the text is kind of fuzzy on
some of the pages so you can't
completely make it out is the idea that
you also need dragon's blood to create
Valyrian steel so you have obsidian
dragon fire regular steel in dragon's
blood to create these ultimate weapons
even though obsidian by itself is still
pretty badass it's just the idea of you
make more sophisticated weapons that
many many people can use so if you need
dragon's blood to create Valyrian steel
think about
what the implications of that are
Daenerys would either have to cut one of
her dragons to test that theory which
isn't going to go down very well or you
would literally have to kill a dragon
and have people run around the
battlefield with buckets of blood so
that they could collect it and use it
later to create more weapons but it
seems like that's a scenario that's
becoming more and more likely like you
sacrifice a dragon you lose something
great but you also gain something really
powerful in that sacrifice it demands a
blood sacrifice I think that was Anthony
Hopkins that said that on Westworld but
the really cool thing is that now that
we know obsidian was used to build
dragon stone it is very literally a
nuclear bunker that they can survive in
against the night King if he comes south
of the wall they could hole up there as
long as they had food and nothing the
night king or the White Walkers could do
would be able to penetrate the building
because obsidian is so deadly to them
but there was this really important
deleted scene from the hounds vision
where he sees the night King at the wall
and that's where they realized that they
have to go where the big fight is going
to take place it gives you a much better
idea for how the night King is going to
get the army of the Dead south of the
wall the hound says it's where the wall
meets the sea and then the deleted part
was the waves are frozen there's a
castle there so that part didn't appear
on the TV show when he says the waves
are frozen that gives you an idea for
how the night king is going to travel
around the wall that could imply a
number of things but he could also get
to Dragonstone by freezing the seat he's
literally that powerful he could also
probably eventually create a glacier so
that he could travel across the eastern
sea and get to Essos - and do the same
thing there but let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
dragonglass now that we know that it's
basically this Universal thing that you
can use to cure disease you can use it
in your architecture you can use it to
create Valyrian steel you can basically
do just about anything with it it's the
new super item on the show and it just
so happens the Daenerys lives on top of
a mountain of it but what will happen is
the game Thrones comic-con panels on
Friday I'll be doing Comic Con videos
between now and then and then Episode
two obviously all that stuff will be on
Sunday and I'll be posting pictures from
the Game of Thrones event tonight on
Twitter and Facebook the links for that
are down in the description if you
want to see that stuff but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner feather dragon please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything click here for
the episode 2 trailer video again and
you can click here for my Comic Con
playlist for all those videos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight